before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
[Music]
huh
it it really is starting to feel
targeted
the release of these things
just to mess with whatever else I've got
going on
I don't know for certain what day I'll
get this out but I am in fact recording
it on Christmas Day
Davies
stop messing with me
or at least do something in your next
tease that makes it clear you're
targeting me in specific then I'll know
you're just trying to piss me off
anyways we have a teaser for the 60th
anniversary now depending on how this
goes in terms of copyright claims
because BBC is weird and wonky they have
a tendency to claim things over 10
seconds trailers they'll sometimes let
go
this entire thing may end up on the main
Channel
the immediate reaction may up may end up
in the break room and then more thorough
thoughts on the channel I don't know
I don't know BBC makes my life hard too
and also they suck for other reasons
which you saw at the front end uh tag
but in any case
let's take a look
sometimes I think there's something
missing
I bet you do Donna
like I had something
okay that hurts
cool
I don't know who I am anymore the show
is just beginning
what are you up to
she will die
we are holding that she's not there you
can't see him
[Music]
someone tell me what the hell is going
on here
like to know I would like to know that
too
so
don't forget to click below to subscribe
wow
oh it's so weird hearing him say that
okay
so it is as most teasers tend to be
light on specifics but there's a couple
things we can glean here
Donna
does has that have that sense that
something's missing that's not a total
shock there were small moments of that
and wolf kind of talked about it in
um the end of time where he noticed like
sometimes she gets this look
so
um that's not a completely new thing the
idea that part of her
not necessarily members but she knows
something's missing which first of all
ow right now
right in the fields ha so there's that
uh for starters and yeah that really
looked like beep the meep
so if you aren't deep into fairly
obscure Doctor Who lore and or missed
when this became a big thing in the
discourse of things like Doctor Who
fandoms on Twitter back when Twitter
wasn't a raging dumpster fire at all
hours
um beep for me is a cute and cuddly and
furry and big-eyed creature originating
from the monthly comic strips that were
in Doctor Who monthly and
so far as I understand beep the Meep
um because I don't I like I looked into
him a little which is why I recognized
him like I'm I'm not deep enough into
nor until Lord to have recognized them
if he hadn't had like conversations had
about him because people were joking
that he was going to show up in this I
can't remember now if that was actually
based off anything or if people were
just randomly joking about it
to my understanding beat the Meep is
actually a bit villainous uh or at least
at the very least not trustworthy so
I'll be interested to see how that plays
out if I were to guess that's going to
be a small Easter eggy kind of
appearance
um I fully expect that
um Neil Patrick Harris's character which
I feel like we can fairly safely assume
is the celestial toy maker
at least that's what I'm going to assume
until proven other otherwise I think we
can still assume he's going to be the
primary uh villain especially because so
all right how am I gonna put this
given that they are tipping the hand
that beep the Meep is in this and RTD
should be Savvy enough of how the fandom
tends to operate that they would have
recognized him and it you know even the
ones who didn't win they would they
would have caught on because it would
have spread uh amongst the fans and then
people would you know realize oh not
normally trustworthy so having beat the
Meep end up being villainous would I
think would only have worked if he was
not in some way hinted at shown or
teased prior to the release of the
special I think within that it could
have worked if he just showed up because
then whoever didn't recognize him would
be surprised but now there's enough time
for everyone to figure out who the heck
that is except for people who like go
way out of their way to avoid spoilers
and
I'd say bless you folks but you're
probably not even watching this if
you're that dedicated to it
so my assumption is that he's going to
be covered as a very minor note or
possibly even just as the cold open
I don't expect him to get a ton of time
uh we get the exact same glimpse of
shurigatwa which works as a punctuation
on the trailer especially as a closing
note for you know the doctor being like
I don't know who I am anymore and Dr B
likes who is that person and her mother
you know be like you you can't see him
and to ha like just in terms of the
terms in terms of I'm tired it's
Christmas Day in terms of the build of
the trailer building up to shoot going
what the hell is going on here
um I'm doing the accent wrong forgive me
but you know building up to him doing
that
um that definitely works it is still a
little bit disappointing that it is the
same clip that we've already seen of him
so if they were going to show him again
I wish we would have seen a little more
but then again I suppose it's probably
best not to oversell his presence in the
60th given that presumably he will
appear either only at the very end of
these specials uh at the point of her
generation or uh possibly be hinted at
prior to that and it's probably not
something that should that should be
over emphasized because then you run the
risk of basically having shown nearly
all of his screen time in just the
trailer so like I both get and am
disappointed by it being the exact same
clip in the exact same line
um yeah Oh Donna hit me in the fields
really hard it was interesting seeing
your mother again I I don't I have mixed
feelings about her mother not like as a
character I don't think she's a bad
character I mean like as a person
you know she's she's not
she's not a great person and she
certainly hasn't been a particularly
helpful or supportive mother she loves
Donna I don't I don't think she doesn't
love Donna but you know her love is
um
I don't know uh
slightly acidic
they they haven't shown wealth yet they
seem to be holding back uh for that
which depending on how much he appears
in it again might be preserving you know
that or maybe even saving it for later
teases because that would make sense as
a build because like our first very like
little tiny clips and glimpses were
tenant Neil Patrick Harris and
shirigatwa
um and now we're getting a little bit
more Adana a little bit more of her
mother uh we get a glimpse of Rose this
new character named Rose who we don't
really know the deal with yet we get
beep the Meep we get these insectoid
looking things which might be something
somebody uh with a more thorough
knowledge of Doctor Who monsters will
probably identify those
um I don't recognize them
um but you know we're so we're getting
these more glimpses but if they're you
know we're still a ways off
from these airing so it would make sense
to hold back some stuff until
further teasers I suspect that truly the
only reason that this was released now
is to have something go out on Christmas
because Davis has expressed his desire
you know to really have Doctor Who be a
major part of the holidays again and
given that there is no new episode to
air for not even just for Christmas but
for holidays at all not even a new year
special this year this is I suspect kind
of the substitute for that
um otherwise I think this this trailer
would have come out some months down the
road but they're still going to need to
do some new trailers later on to build
up to the actual release and I think
waiting on willf to later trailer would
make a lot of sense so I expect later
trailers are gonna clarify a little bit
more about Neil Patrick Harris who he's
at least who he's playing if not what
he's up to
um show us wealth
um maybe give us a little more sense of
Rose it depends it depends on how much
RTD wants to give away in advance and
and or how much of this is a misdirect
because he's kind of known for doing
that too but we'll see as a as a trailer
as a minute long trailer
it is solid
it's a solid piece of work it has me
intrigued it has it adds in enough new
elements that it's not having me going
yeah okay no this tells me nothing new
this does tell me some stuff new but
also not a ton I don't know everything
that's going to go on especially given
that there are three specials and I'm
right now presuming that most if not all
of the clips we have seen are only going
to be from the first special that's my
own assumption that's not based on
anything I have no Insider knowledge
that's just my own assumption
and hope because I've mentioned this
before in general I'm the kind of person
who when I see something in a trailer
part of my brain doesn't fully relax
until we've gotten to see it in the
thing
um which does mean that sometimes things
fully not showing up in trailers
actually really irritates me
um just in terms of part of my brain
never real never relaxes
um so if only for that reason I'm hoping
like maybe the shooting got to a clip
but I'm hoping as little as possible
ideally none of the rest of it is
actually stuff from later specials
because it's part of me will never relax
watching that first special if there are
chunks of footage like oh we still don't
know what's going on with all the
that's a me thing
it's a pretty good piece
and despite this disrupting my day
again
with these little drops
um I am smiling
so
it's obviously doing something right
I like the tone of tenants doctor I like
that he is unsure that he is on the back
foot
if only because a big part of his
Persona during his era was Swagger and
confidence and like many of the times
when that was shaken up was some of the
best stuff
midnight I know it's something a lot of
folks like about uh Waters of Mars I'm
not as hot on that one as other people
but like
when it's there it's really interesting
when he's not so confident when he's not
so oh I am very good in all of that when
he's less sure of himself interesting
things happen not necessarily better
things inherently but if we've only gone
for a short time especially to start I
would like to see him unsure questioning
not fully confident
because that's something that can build
over the special so that by the time
tenant wraps up this short run
regeneration
he can get back to that confidence
and in my mind ideally
be far more accepting of the
Regeneration
and that could be his own little mini
Arc across these
that starting out so unsure because he
was supposed to be done and now he's
back but he doesn't know why and to have
him go through whatever the adventure is
and build that confidence back up
but with that not necessarily the
arrogance that led to his little temper
tantrum at the end of uh time part two
that's like the funny thing is this
wasn't an expectation I had before this
is one I've kind of talked myself into
that's kind of what I would like to see
I don't do this often I don't generally
do the this is what I want to see thing
but as far as an arc for tenant's
character
I would like to see him on Shore gain
confidence but also be accepting
that he is not here to stay this time
yeah
this thing must be doing something right
because it's not theorizing but it I I
am placing hopes which I generally don't
do partly because my brain doesn't
really work that way most of the time
um but also just because you know you
place expectations on it you can get let
down but I can't help it it kind of
happened
I am excited
and like I'm on the record as tenant
being a middling doctor like he's good
but I've got a lot I prefer over him but
I'm still real excited for this
dang it Davies
[Music]
got me again
what did you think of this trailer
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about patreon what pays the bills
um and sometimes means I have to stop my
holiday in order to jump on stuff but um
you know it helps ensure that I can eat
and have holidays and you know take care
of my family and all that uh any amount
you can give is a great assistance even
if you can't do that like share
subscribe are huge helps there's links
to other things I do down in the
description that help me out but uh
don't worry too too much about that
I don't know what outro to do because
this will either be in the main room or
the break room depending on what the
copyright does
we'll do the main outro what I want you
to remember
whether this goes out on Christmas Day
or the day after
I want you to remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
oh
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters kimudelki leotha Boyd catoria
toy lowly Becky Sparks for navilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Jayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
how you doing there
[Music]